the Democratic Party's effort to make
history in the Florida governor's race
fell short former Republican congressman
Ron De Santis beat Tallahassee mayor
Andrew Gilliam by less than sixty
thousand votes Gilliam would have been
Florida's first black governor
Republicans may have also flipped a
Senate seat in Florida Democratic
Senator Bill Nelson is trailing outgoing
Governor Rick Scott by about thirty
eight thousand votes and there may have
to be a recount Manuel Vargas is at the
governor's mansion in Tallahassee Manny
good morning good morning that race and
the one to determine who will now live
here at the governor's mansion were as
high profile as it gets both parties
poured millions of dollars into the
state and while polls showed the
Democrats might be able to pull off a
victory in the end the nation's third
most populous state went largely red
governor elect Ron de Santos took the
stage in Orlando pledging to work for
all Floridians I don't care if you were
against me in the campaign I want to
work with you to advance our common
priorities in his concession speech
Tallahassee mayor Andrew Gilliam struck
a more defiant tone encouraging
disappointed supporters not to give up I
can guarantee you this I'm not going
anywhere we're gonna fight we're gonna
keep fighting the vote broke heavily
along racial lines Gilliam won nearly 70
percent of the state's non-white voters
he also won more than 60% of voters aged
18 to 44 but DeSantis won 60% of white
voters and 54% of Floridians age 45 and
older by far the largest voting group in
the election I'd like to thank our
president for standing by me
DeSantis had the full throttle support
of the president and campaigned with him
in the days leading up to the election
along with his predecessor Rick Scott
in the state Senate race Scott declared
a premature victory over three-term
incumbent Senator Bill Nelson
I'm not going to DC to win a popularity
contest I'm going to DC to get something
done
Nelson is behind by around thirty eight
thousand votes a number close enough to
trigger an automatic recount under
Florida law let's get to work
senator Nelson has not conceded as the
last votes are being counted in the
meantime the voting landscape could be
changing for 2020 and that's because
Florida voters approved an amendment
that would restore the Voting Rights of
convicted felons who have served their
time and that could add more than a
million new voters to the rolls here
Noora and that will have implications in
2020 men well thank you